[Musica]
ma vedo tutto questo casino
che strano
[Musica]
non c'è nessuno forse mi sono immaginata
tutto
[Musica]
beh sì se c'è qualcuno
da dove viene questa musica
sentite anche voi forse il vicino di
casa che sta suonando
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ah ok ho capito forse di quelle tastiere
che suonano da sol e avete presente
quelle che insomma fanno le musichette
da sole
ok dimmi subito chi sei
so benissimo che c'è qualcosa che non va
chi sei
dimmi che cosa vuoi da me
sapete che quando succedono queste
strane cose paranormali in casa vuol
dire che c'è qualche intruso un
biglietto bene scopriamo pure che cosa
si aspetta
ma come non ti ricordi di me
il tuo nemico più simpatico di tutti
l'uomo invisibile
ti avevo promesso che sarei tornato
e ora trovami se ci riesci e se non ci
riesci meglio che scappi
ok cerchiamo subito unasco di gesù
ridiamoci ma se non avete ancora
lasciato un mi piace mi raccomando
lasciate un bel mi piace se questo video
raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace ci sarà un
altro episodio con l'uomo invisibile
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
stupito la ciao ragazzi dobbiamo
sbrigarci a scegliere il primo
nascondiglio
l'uomo invisibile potrebbe essere
ovunque qua qua i salti d'acqua riesco a
vedere qualcosa ovviamente non riesco a
vedere l'uomo invisibile ma magari
riesco a vedere se c'è qualche oggetto
fluttuante un qualcosa di strano
tenete gli occhi bene aperti anche voi
[Musica]
ok ragazzi sono scappata in studio
avete visto l'uomo invisibile stava
spostando i divani e le spettava per
prendermi ma non sei riuscito ora devo
subito trovare un altro nascondiglio
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa di strano qui io o c'è
qualcuno che sta dormendo sul letto lo
vedete anche voi c'è una coperta e lo so
sembra che ci sia qualcuno sotto che
faccio insomma coperta potrebbe essere
rischioso ma devo riuscire io a trovare
l'uomo invisibile così vincono cialde
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa no provò ad afferrarlo
preso no non c'è niente maledizione
finché non trovo l'uomo invisibile e
finché lui non mi trova nessuno dei due
avrà vinto la challenge ma noi dobbiamo
pensare alla challenge quindi
sbrighiamoci e cerchiamo un posto in cui
non darci un'idea se un posto in cui è
molto difficile che si trovi il nostro
nascondiglio sono nascosti dietro a un
tapis roulant per l'edilizia è arrivato
il primo il legno c'è un bambino mi
raccomando non devi far sapere al mondo
invisibile che siamo nascosti qui ok
anzi magari tutto fantastico fiuto da
cani riesce a capire dove l'uomo
invisibile mi aiuti ok va bene grazie
penso che riuscirò mai a trovarmi qua
vero merlino una palla
c'è verdura in silenzio a parma che
succede sta effettuando
vita
[Musica]
per un pelo non è visibile mi stava
minacciando con una palla da ginnastica
forse cieco come ha fatto non vedermi
c'è magari lui al super potere di essere
invisibile ma magari è cieco non lo so
comunque dobbiamo elaborare subito un p
ha un'idea in mente
prendiamo una coperta e quando penso che
lui si stia avvicinando il ritiriamo
sopra la coperta così vedremo dove è
così potrò legarlo e lo avrò catturato
dentro alla coperta
spero che funzioni dobbiamo innanzitutto
andare a prendere la coperta in camera
fini berlino con la coperta
dobbiamo tendergli una trappola sentito
questo cuore avendo al piano di sopra
sentite i pazzi è andato a nascondersi
al piano di sopra
sappiamo anche noi al piano di sopra di
facciamo una trappola e butterò la
coperta addosso e lo catturerà così
vincerò la salle
compreso
[Musica]
c'è nessuno uomo invisibile spaventato
questa mozione pd mi raccomando se
vedete qualcosa di strano scrivete me lo
hai sentito berlino
[Musica]
qualcosa qua
l'altro che porta forse qualche parte
[Musica]
no maledizione non c'è niente
ma dove berlino dove c'è timido ma
berlino
nino dove qua
parlino
papà
loretello sofisticato ma invisibile
[Applauso]
giudicati positivi che berlino 3 2 1 ma
no non c'è nessuno questo ad essere
riuscito a scappare l'affido è capito
grazie per questi bacini di batte perché
abbiamo per foraggiare lanzi nuovamente
vediamo cosa c'è scritto qualche hit sì
lo so chi sei impaziente aspetta lo
stesso berlino brava hai vinto questa
challenge ma non la battaglia non posso
svelarvi chi sono forse quando tornerò
non svelerò a presto sarà a berlino
anche se non abbiamo scoperto chi è
l'uomo invisibile
abbiamo comunque vinto la challenge
abbiamo vinto questo nascondino se
volete vedere altri video che un nome
visibili altri video nascondino molto
difficili lasciate un bel mi piace e ora
vi lascio quattro cartelli su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao ciao e che da vero
si no